welcome to the five everybody that was
joe biden
and kamala harris for the first time
together the 2020
ticket kind of a rickety roll out um
maybe three hours late but they finally
got together and joe biden got up there
talked about kamala harris's biography
how she has always been a fighter for
the middle class
someone has taken on the big banks big
oil and the big gun lobby
and someone who has always kept her
family very close the daughter of
immigrant parents
and there they are together with their
spouses
waiting at a kind of an empty gym but uh
it is
obviously a time of a pandemic so we
have social distancing in place
joe biden then pivoted to talking about
president trump
saying that obviously the attacks on
kamala harris shows that the president
does not like women and
we can expect more attacks like that
then he announced it he
made this big announcement on the
anniversary of charlottesville
invoking adolf hitler and the klu klux
klan
then handed it off to kamala harris who
came out and very eloquently
delivered a speech uh talking about the
biden family how compassionate and
empathetic they are in her relationship
to the late son
beau biden and talked about her
biography how she was raised to be
a fighter for the people and a fighter
for justice then kind of framed the race
as
about competence there was the ebola
crisis that joe biden handled with only
two deaths
she said donald trump has mishandled
the coronavirus pandemic and now we have
over 160
000 deaths in the united states so
obviously
framing this race about race about the
economic
hit we've taken and about the
coronavirus dana perino
what are your thoughts on this as we
also await donald trump's news
conference
in a little bit yeah but i think that
the president will probably give that
just a little bit of breathing room um
so that everybody can take that in
and then move on to the news of the day
that he would um provide and of course
probably a response to that
um so i think one one of the things we
should point out they were a little bit
delayed in getting started because
there's been terrible storms on the east
coast and the power went out
where uh they were going to have their
event it is different to have
a rollout like this taking place in the
middle of a pandemic you saw
that they had to be separated there was
not a big hug between the two of them
but i think if you're the biden campaign
you're pretty happy with how that went
um both speeches given on teleprompter
um
and i think the other thing that she
said in addition to all the points that
you made jessie is she talked about
how this if they were to win it doesn't
just need to be
a win it has to be a mandate they're
looking to try to see if they can figure
out a way
to not just win by a little bit they
want to be able to win so that they can
figure out how to move forward on their
agenda
i think that you also saw that you know
for a lot of americans this might be the
first time they're actually ever
listening to a speech
by kamala harris a lot of people don't
not every american pays attention during
a democratic primary
and she didn't even make it to the early
states to get a chance to even be voted
on the first time she dropped out in
december of 2019.
so she has an opportunity here to have a
second chance at making a first
impression
and i think that you saw that the
democrats have really closed ranks
all around they have a staff all ready
to go to be able to support her i
thought sarah palin's
advice to her that she provided last
night was really good including
the one of don't trust anybody new right
have your own team around you because
sarah palin still looks back
at what happened to her in 2008 and
thinks that that was one of the things
that was just absolutely terrible
that happened to her on that campaign
the last thing i would say
is that i think you will see her out a
little bit more it is not sustainable
to run for a campaign and to only do one
or two events a week
she said it there's 83 days left to go
so this is a
probably the one of the best days that
the biden harris campaign will have
the rest might get a little bit messier
from here i would agree with that greg
what did you think about
dana's point that you know she is not a
well-known
politician the way you think of a bernie
sanders uh
even elizabeth warren hillary clinton a
joe biden
what do you think she did for herself in
today's speech
well for one thing she sold out the cops
so let's
that was like the thing that really
stood out to me is that she sold out she
was a cop
but she's no longer a cop uh the other
thing it is a two-way race in the sense
that it's going to be about race and
it's going to be about race
you saw joe biden trot out the fine
people hoax
which has already been discredited trump
wasn't talking about racists he was
talking about
both sides of the statue debate debate
anybody with half a brain i.e joe knows
that
uh so he's but he mentions the clan this
from a guy who spoke
at a funeral for a klansman okay trump
didn't speak at a funeral for a klansman
joe biden did but i guess we forgot
about that then he said something
totally mind-boggling
that said that trump coddled terrorists
and i'm thinking i'd go like
okay this is from a guy who was against
taking out bin laden
and trump got rid of isis solemni in
al-baghdadi so is he losing his mind or
is he just flat out lying
lastly and this is why i hate politics
and politics is bs
because it shows you how awful people
can be
i've heard the kamala beau uh biden
story and it
about the strong connection between
kamala and bo but i i i wonder if she
knew so much and learned so much about
joe's character
through this close relationship with
beau biden why did she
say she believed the sex abuse accusers
of joe biden and why did she smear him
as a racist sympathizer
with segregationists if she had learned
so much from beau biden
and it's probably because she's just
lying and if her
if if she can make an attack like that
on joe biden
for for debate theatrics months ago
it's reasonable to conclude that the
ruination of brett kavanaugh
was also just hearing theatrics that she
will ruin you
for political reasons so if you are new
to politics
you've learned a sober lesson it's
complete and utter bs
people will say anything to get power
so what she did was she was willing to
crush kavanaugh and crush
joe biden but when pow when the door
opens up for power
that all goes out the window absolutely
valid questions that need to be answered
she said a lot of things about joe biden
and
eventually she'll have to answer those
questions let's bring in bret baer
chief political anchor special report
earlier today brett you were talking
about
seeing two people up on stage and
getting a sense of the chemistry
what did you think of the chemistry of
these two individuals
that's the ticket yeah it's a little
tough isn't it in this uh
coveted times with social distancing and
everything else and then
empty uh gym where they're waving to
essentially 12 reporters in duct tape
circles that are six feet apart and
it's empty and they pump the music in
it's kind of a weird surreal
moment but i think what you saw in those
speeches was an
effort to tie the two together uh to
show that they are
simpatico in joe biden's words and
their their real string together was
that they both spent a lot of time going
after donald trump
and i think that that's what you're
going to see out of kambla harris really
on the attack in a prosecutorial way
i agree with dana that there was a piece
of this was
that was about introducing senator
harris
to the american public because every
network took it and there will be a lot
of eyeballs to see
what this ticket looks like let's bring
in geraldo rivera
speaking about the ticket geraldo what
do you think the addition of kamala to
the ticket does to
for joe biden is it where does it
energize him where does it help him
what are your thoughts you know jesse
they say that nobody votes for
vice president uh except this time
they may be when i look at joe biden and
i really think he's a decent person and
every time i see him i like him
uh however we're almost the same age
he's eight months older than i am but
he's an old 77.
he has a fragility about him a fragile
nature
that it just seems to me that you look
at kamala harris and you look at
the person who will be the 46th
president of the united states
uh not necessarily four years now god
bless him i hope he lives forever
uh that's just my my instinct just
looking at my impression just looking at
him
in terms of kamala harris herself uh
senator harris i
i think that what everybody has missed
up until this point is
this is history man this is a very big
deal
this is a woman who's got a reasonable
chance of being the next vice president
she's a woman of color she's a black
woman she's a south asian
woman you know i think that you
you minimize her to uh to your uh
to your detriment i think that she had
me all the way until she
took a dig at fox news which i thought
was unnecessary
and she also mentioned glowingly black
lives matter
in the same week where the black lives
matter leader in chicago
said that the looting uh was reparations
uh
you know for the historic injustice that
black people have suffered
i think that she's got to divorce
herself from at least the
most radical aspects of black lives
matter she's got to embrace a centrist
position i think she will i think she
really is a sensational
you know pick for him for all the
reasons
that i mentioned she's a prosecutor the
weakness
that she had in the democratic primary
was because she was tough on law and
order and put all those pot smokers
in jail i i think that that kind of
stuff might help her with
a fringe in the general election so i
think that this is a win
for the democrats i think joe's got to
come out of the basement
uh he can't ask pamela kamala to carry
the ticket for him but they have in
senator harris an effective
formidable weapon to use against the
the trump pence uh ticket to use against
donald trump
i strongly advise president trump not to
go after kamala harris go after joe
biden don't
don't go after her but my wife and all
her democratic friends are elated
at this uh at this choice i think that
this spells uh
uh you know trouble for the republicans
they're gonna they have their hands full
the polls already indicate that
and i think she has strengthened biden's
hand
well i'll uh i'll i'll
see your democratic friends and and i'll
i'll double down on that because i have
democratic friends too geraldo and i
don't think there is
elated at the kamala harris pick as your
friends are
uh judge jeanine pirro gerald rivera
talked about
vice president joe biden's fragility and
as greg godfeld mentioned the other day
on the show i think about
half of the democrats polled don't even
believe joe biden is going to finish
the first term if he's elected what does
that tell you
about harris as a pick for vice
president
well i i have a lot of thoughts the
first thought that i have jesse is
for some reason i just have this feeling
that joe biden isn't going to be on the
ticket
i have a sense that something's going to
happen before
the election and he's not even going to
be on the ticket so don't even ask me if
he's going to make the four years
but let me just tell you a little bit
about what i saw
you know as as a woman myself i was a
first woman d.a i was a first woman
county judge that kind of stuff
uh it is momentous geraldo you are right
but i think that that's because
you know we didn't see it when we were
younger and maybe some people see it as
a big deal but in the
end it's not about the vp it's about the
presidential candidate
now let me tell you what the problem is
with the speech she gave
as polished as she is and as clear as
she is
in terms of what her attacks will be i'm
tired of people
lying to me and i get really disgusted
when they start saying that
donald trump destroyed the economy and
this whole covent problem
is all about donald trump here's the
bottom line
joe biden and and barack obama couldn't
put the economy together donald trump
did
all right and the truth is that in terms
of covid
it was donald trump who stopped the
flies from coming in i don't have to go
over all those facts
because you know them but when she
stands up and she says
look we're going to get this country
back online we're going to make it
economically successful again
and in the same breath she talked about
the clean what
what did she say the the uh the new deal
there
uh um uh i think it was she said the
uh the california clean new deal
whatever it is she's a she's a person
who supports
the green new deal she's against
fracking they're going to get rid of
hundreds of thousands of jobs she's
going to lose ohio
west virginia and pennsylvania so how is
that going to help americans
and by the way as a candidate from
california which is a blue state
how is how does that help but the most
important issue in addition to covert
right now
is what's going on in our cities around
the country she wants to give kudos to
black
lives matter she wants to talk about the
fact that
you know we're going to we're going to
go after a system of criminal justice
that has systemic
racism in it what did you do about it
when you were the a.g what did you do
about it when you were the district
attorney
and since when have you changed your
stripes so she's got a lot to answer
about and in the end i think she's an
inauthentic candidate and i think that
like joe biden who wrote the crime bill
she's got a lot to answer for yeah the
inauthenticity that's something that
the president mentioned yesterday about
her phoniness and we certainly don't
hope
that anything happens to vice president
joe biden anytime soon let's bring in
bret baer again one more time you heard
judge jeanine talk about
kamala harris's pretty far left
record um the media tried to cast her
today the new york times called her a
pragmatic moderate but when you go down
the list of things she's said
and done and voted for it stacks up is
pretty liberal
what are your thoughts about that yeah
first of all let me just say that i
respect judge janine's opinions and her
fiery passion about things
last night was the last democratic
debate democratic primary
connecticut where 60 delegates uh went
to
uh joe biden so he is going to be the
nominee and next week we're going to see
the official nomination
you're saying that he doesn't make it
all the way uh i
it's the bumper stickers are already
printed it's biden harris and he's
he's going to be the nominee as of next
week but let me just say this
that there is this effort to make her
more moderate
than her voting record is and just if
you look at the data
she has one of the more liberal if not
the most liberal
voting records in the senate definitely
for 2019
and if you look at the the stats about
bipartisan outreach
she is down at the bottom of that list
uh 88 and one
one survey 93 out of uh all of the
senators there so
just on the stats you can make the the
case but pragmatic moderate is a tougher
case to make for the new york times
that's right all right and we're
and can i say something jesse i just
want to say something
look i i wish him all good health that's
not what i'm talking about he's got the
numbers
but things are so crazy right now i i
don't know what's
what's happening in the democrat party
and that's all i'm saying i mean i hope
he lives forever that's not my point
right and i know he's got the numbers
right right we understand all right uh
again still awaiting president trump's
news conference
at the white house briefing